hey it's Justine and I am so hyped
because as you know the new iPhone 15s
are officially out in the world and so
is IOS 17 and what's great about iOS 17
is it's not just new to the brand new
iPhones you can also get it on older
devices as well and I love iOS upgrades
because it really does make your phone
feel brand new now let's go into some of
the features that I've been loving so
far
standby has been awesome you can scroll
through different widgets there's photos
it's super easy you just scroll through
there's a bunch of different clock
Styles so you can choose whichever one
you like the most standby works when
your phone is plugged in and turned
sideways and I love these magsafe
charging stands because it makes it so
much more seamless they have new contact
posters which allow you to create a
custom contact image that will be sent
to anyone else who has iOS 17 and this
way this lets you control what image
pops up on your phones because I know
some of my friends right now have really
awful photos of me which is kind of
comical but now I can send them a really
nice one what I like about this is you
can set up different contact pictures
and photos and content within each
contact poster to send to different
people so if there's someone who you may
not want to have your phone number you
have the ability to send them a
different contact poster that's
specifically for that reason I think
these are really fun and it's a nice
Personal Touch now kind of going along
with contact posters is name drop you
just have to bring your phones close to
each other just like this and
automatically Tyler and I have shared
our contacts with name drop and again
each party can choose which contact
poster and information that they want to
share and if they don't want to share
well you don't have to do that either oh
this one is one of my favorites it's
live voicemail now I don't like talking
on the phone so I definitely get a lot
of voicemails and yeah it's cool that
you can go back and see the voice
transcriptions but what if it's actually
really important so now as they're
leaving the voicemail this is all being
transcribed in real time and you can
choose to answer it if it seems like
something that you want to talk about
also something to help beat spam is that
if there's a call that's identified as
like a scam number Apple will
automatically send that to voicemail and
not transcribe it so you don't actually
have to worry about any car insurance
scams which is pretty nice there's some
new iMessage features like this swipe to
reply so when you swipe to the right
this will allow you to reply in line to
the text so as you see here I'm chat
with Tyler he wants to know if we're
still on for 8 A.M but it's nine o'clock
he's getting a breakfast burrito so
I'm okay with that I know this is really
helpful because a lot of my friends will
spam texts and when I try to reply to a
specific thing this makes it really easy
and it shows you exactly what you're
replying to so there's no confusion
whatsoever we now have interactive
widgets previously when you would tap a
widget it would just open the app itself
you really couldn't do anything it would
just kind of serve you information and
kind of just be a shortcut right to the
app but now they're actually interactive
so you can do things inside of the
widget like my to-do list this now has
improved autocorrect so when I type
[Music]
it doesn't
change it to duck all jokes aside though
this is actually super helpful because
there are a lot of times when it would
auto correct things either things that I
have accidentally auto corrected and
have inserted into the Siri system
everything now just feels more cohesive
it doesn't feel like it's overly auto
correcting but of course my favorite
feature is making stickers the easiest
way to do this is taking a live photo
and here we go let's see what should I
do
yeah that's great it's really great now
we take our live photo we go into our
stickers we add it as a sticker and
there it is so I like that you can go
into these and add different effects so
I can make it an outline comic puffy or
shiny let's do a shiny stab that's nice
there's another really cool feature
called check-in which I really like this
is going to be great for people to give
a heads up of like hey I'm on the way
here's my check-in if you don't arrive
at your destination you have the option
to send your current location of where
you are if your friend checks in just in
case something happens all that
information will be there and it looks
like I'm getting a check-in request from
Tyler oh he said second I'll receive a
notification when he arrives home at 11
15. if they are delayed or their phone
places an emergency SOS you'll receive a
notification of their location so it
looks like Tyler's on his way to
Portland but he's in Los Angeles right
now so he's gonna get there around 11 15
p.m so I don't know we're not gonna wait
around for that one
okay and the check-in has ended because
Tyler decided that he's not actually
going to be driving back to Portland
right now so there it is this is a cool
feature they've now added access to
offline maps so you're able to download
a portion of the map and still get
turn-by-turn directions and even search
for restaurants or places within that
vicinity this is great if you're
traveling abroad and you don't want to
use your cellular service you can
download the maps before you leave the
hotel and you'll be able to still have
those turn-by-turn directions and search
for places you want to visit oh also you
now no longer have to say hey when you
want to talk to our friend
Siri
I have so many Syrian able devices here
like I don't even know which one
answered a Siri from over there answered
it's also nice because now you can
stream multiple serial quests without
having to say Siri in between so it's a
nice conversation between our friends
Siri
hope you have a nice day
thanks I hope you have a nice day too oh
I'm touched Siri what's five plus five
plus five is ten where can I find a math
tutor here's what I found
do you want to go to the mall later
she didn't like that one so that's it
for some of the iOS 17 features that I
really like let me know what your
favorites are in the comments below if
you want to check out some more Apple
videos you can do so here on the end
screen and of course check out my
YouTube channel for more youtube.com
iJustine lots more videos there for you
to watch see ya
[Music]